We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the former president of the Acl,
you a board member for fire,
epic and the Heterodox Academy,
a professor at New York law school and
author of the new book hate why we
should resist it with free speech,
not censorship,
Nadian Strauss and welcome to the Rubin
report to be here,
Dave.
So I have to tell you when I was reading
through your bio and looking at all the
boards you've sat on and head of Acl,
you and all that,
I don't know that anyone has ever been
more of sort of a perfect prime guests
to sit in that chair and my prayer book
defending pornography that caught your
attention.
We can get into that too,
but really your,
your life's work is sort of exactly why
I do this show and I know I'm setting
you up now with a very high bar here,
but.
But this is what it's all about.
Thank you so much and thank you for your
ardent defense of liberty.
That is the most important value for me.
And when people ask me what my politics
are,
I usually say I care more about my civil
libertarian beliefs than I care about
partisan political beliefs,
and one of the things that's true for
the Acu as well as for me as an
individual is not taking per say,
across the board positions on any
candidate,
official party or group,
but judging on an issue by issue basis
and issuing a criticism or a or praise
on an issue by issue basis and there's
not a single party or candidate or
official that hasn't earned some praise
and some criticism on some important
civil liberties issues.
So looking at the glass half full as an
activist,
I always do that.
There's nobody with whom I don't share
some really strong convictions,
which is very nice.
Now it's also true that there's nobody
with whom I have some strong
disagreements,
but I'm used to therefore having a
positive relationship across ideological
divides and the absence of that or the
fading of that in today's climate is
very bothersome.
All right.
What a great place to start this
conversation then.
So as you've seen that fail,
that fade in society,
do you have a couple of markers or
moments where you started to really see
it or has it just been a slow slide into
wherever it seems that we're at at the
moment?
That's a really good question,
Dave,
and I'm sure some sociologists have
probably analyze it more.
Exactly.
My impression is,
at least on issues,
let's stay with issues of free speech.
Uh,
my strong impression is that there
started to be a real breaking point in
around 2015.
Uh,
I think that's when we had the ferguson.
I'm a riots and uh,
demonstrations and protests around the
country and I am completely sympathetic
to that cause believe me,
abuses in the criminal justice system.
I have been on my radar screen and the
acl for ever a way back in the dark ages
or some would say the ages of the I
meant only in the sense of old wasn't a
stigmatizing referenced,
but the Reagan administration.
I used to debate his attorney,
General Ed meese on proposition such as
is the criminal justice system racially
discriminatory.
So the,
and I was taking the yes,
possession,
so the fact that we have this outpouring
and support of social justice and Racial
Justice and uh,
immigrants rights and antisexual
violence,
all of that is wonderful.
But starting several years ago,
it started to seem more and more that
advocates of these causes began to see
free speech as their enemy rather than
what I know it to be,
which is they're time tested essential
ally.
Uh,
so there was this pitting of liberty
against equality of civil rights,
against civil liberties.
And as I say that,
I realized that it was the second time
that had happened in my adult lifetime.
The first time that,
that happened very strongly was in the
late 19 eighties,
early 19 nineties,
which was the first time that hate
speech codes were proposed on college
campus.
It's the first time we started seeing
criticism of what was called political
correctness.
And then to,
especially law professors were arguing
very strongly that you have to choose.
You can't have both liberty and
equality.
And that's anathema to my own beliefs
and experience.
And that's kind of where we're at right
now.
That seems to be where this argument has
boiled down to.
So before we unpack all of that stuff,
how did you get involved in this?
What was it about your education or your
upbringing or whatever else that made
you care about free speech,
civil liberties,
everything else that you've just
mentioned it as far back as I can
remember.
I have been in favor of individual
liberty and resisting anybody who tried
to encroach on my liberty or that of
anybody else's.
So long before I had the terminology,
I resisted my parents,
authoritarianism,
my school teacher authoritarianism.
Uh,
I was kind of a contrarian.
I would always like to see a different
perspective.
And I remember being very puzzled as a
fairly young student.
Maybe I was about 10 or 11 years old and
a teacher said to me,
own a dean,
why do you always have to defend the
underdog?
And she said it as a criticism and to me
it was,
well,
they're the ones that need the defense.
I have also always valued freedom of
speech for ideas that I disagree with.
So I remember I was in college,
uh,
from 1968 to 1972,
a very involved in the movement against
the Vietnam War Movement for
reproductive freedom.
That was before the Supreme Court
decided Roe v Dot Wade again,
that really dark ages,
um,
but I also always defended freedom for
people who disagreed with me,
so I would have lot big arguments with
members of SDS students for Democratic
Society,
very radical organization that wanted to
shout down certain speakers that were in
favor of the Vietnam war administration
officials and so forth.
And while I disagreed with the points of
view of those speakers,
I didn't believe it that they should,
that we should be denying them a podium.
So as far back as I remember,
I've been a,
I cared much more about freedom in part
because I do see that as the essential
means to advance whatever other cause is
dear to you.
It's hard to defend the people that you
don't like,
isn't it?
It seems to me that that's the one we're
forgetting these days.
Like everyone screams about free speech
all the time.
The second someone says they don't like,
then they kind of get quiet real quick.
Well,
so I was shortly after I graduated from
law school,
uh,
the Acu and I was not involved at the
national level at all at that point,
but the acl,
you got involved in the infamous or
famous skokie case and that was like a
real litmus test.
I assume most viewers know what that is,
but for those who might not in 1977,
the acu came to the defense of the free
speech rights of a group of neo Nazis
who wanted to demonstrate in Skokie,
Illinois a suburb of Chicago that had a
large Jewish population and a large
population of Holocaust survivors and
many members of the acl,
you even this stalwart,
free speech organization a loss.
We lost about 15 percent of our members
who said,
we really defend free speech,
but this is the one exception we want to
make for this absolutely abhorrent
speech.
Now my father is a holocaust survivor.
I have to say was sadly he died,
but it wasn't even an issue for me.
I have to tell you,
dave,
and it's coming back to your question
because you said something about how
does it feel to defend people that you
disagree with and to me,
I never defending them.
I'm never defending their ideas.
I'm never defending.
What did they say?
I am defending the principle that
government should not have power to
silence speech just because the majority
of the public,
even the vast majority of the public
low.
This despises the idea that the speech
is conveying.
Yeah,
so that's incredible.
Obviously I know the skokie case well
and I'm sure many much of my audiences,
I didn't realize 15 percent did you say
50 percent of the membership of a clu
members.
That's a massive amount of so and and
you know it.
So the ACO,
you really put its money where its mouth
is.
It was a tremendous financial hit,
a and there was a lot of negative press.
Now,
in fairness,
a fairly soon after that,
the ACL,
you began to recoup members,
maybe not necessarily the same people.
In fact,
other people who wrote in and said,
we see that you really aren't neutrally
defending civil liberties even for
people that are anti civil or raised
themselves.
Now.
That's sad.
I have to tell you,
almost every time I give a speech
anywhere,
people will come up to me and say,
I was an acl EU member,
but I quit over skokie and a Ra,
nih,
or who was the executive director at the
time.
And interestingly enough himself,
a Holocaust survivor.
He was born in Berlin.
His extended family was completely
exterminated by the Nazis.
He and his immediate family escaped and,
uh,
and he wrote a wonderful book about it
afterwards called defending my enemy,
which I quote in my book,
uh,
and we can talk about how that might
seem paradoxical,
but it's really not.
But anyway,
in this context,
I brought him up because he said to me,
Nadine,
if every person who said they left the
acl,
you over skokie really had been a
member.
We would have been the largest
organization in the world ever talking
to a game.
But you will see if I can just follow up
on that.
It's not just an abstract principle
because you can really see how the
principal has concrete ramifications for
exactly the opposite idea,
so in our briefs and the skokie case,
we pointed out that the arguments that
were being made to justify suppressing
the Nazis,
namely that their ideas were offensive
and insulting and threatening and seen
as dangerous to the Jews and the
Holocaust survivors in skokie.
That was exactly the same set of
arguments that was made not that much
earlier in 1968 when Martin Luther King
was trying to demonstrate in Cicero,
Illinois,
the very same state,
but with a very different population
that saw his ideas as threatening and
dangerous and subversive,
offensive and insulting,
and this is where this weird subjective
nature of this comes in,
which is why you've said several times
now you're defending the principal,
not the person,
and that that of course is the is the
key to this whole thing,
but we've been pushed
into this place these days where it
seems like there's a large set of people
or certainly a set of very loud people
who think that speech is violent.
It ain't violence well.
I suppose speech could advocate
violence,
it could incite violence,
it could threaten violence.
So do you.
So do you agree with where we have the
law is now in terms of you can't
directly insight and that sort of thing.
Do you think all those laws are are just
inappropriate?
Absolutely,
and I have to say even though I've been
teaching constitutional law,
the First Amendment for decades,
the process of writing this book and
thinking about it and even more focused
fashion really increased my respect for
us law and I really think that for many
people,
if they would just understand what the
law actually provides,
they would be much more supportive of
freedom of speech because it is much
more nuanced and much more common
sensical than is often misdescribe when
people say either,
Oh,
hate speech is not free speech.
We heard here that a lot,
including when you were at the
University of New Hampshire,
we are that a lot.
Right?
And then conversely,
people will say,
Oh,
hate speech is protected and neither
generalization is correct.
Yes,
I.
The fact that speech has a hateful or
hated message idea or content can never
be adjusted if occasion for censoring
it,
but if in a particular context,
a hateful message along with any other
message directly causes certain serious,
specific imminent harm and there's no
way to avert that harm other than
punishing the speech,
then the speech can and should be
punished and common examples that
satisfy that standard are intentional
incitement of imminent violence,
a genuine threat that instills fear that
you're going to be subject to violence.
Um,
uh,
another example is a hate crime and that
is,
it's,
it's a little bit different in the sense
that a,
and I'm going so much into my,
we're going into the weeds,
but that's good.
That's good.
Okay.
So if I can say there is no term hate
speech and that was the point that you
made in your University of New
Hampshire.
Not have said that it's a fact.
Right.
And it's a fact that is subscribed to by
every single supreme court justice
across the ideological spectrum.
You know,
from Ginsburg and Sotomayor on the left
to Alito and gorsuch and Scalia.
On the right,
and I think that's a very,
very important point that for all of
their ideological differences on so many
issues that so many justices,
every justice in modern history has
subscribed to this principal and I wish
that people across the ideological
spectrum in other branches of government
and the general public which share that
unanimity because no matter who you are,
no matter what you believe,
you really have a stake in denying the
government and the majority of of people
that wield power taken away from you.
The choice about which views you will
express or listened to or refute.
So in that University of New Hampshire
speech that I know you watched when,
when I was saying there,
you know,
hate speech is not real.
Obviously.
I was making the distinction between the
direct call to violence,
which I actually said unless it's a
direct call to bounce,
but hate speech in and of itself is,
is nothing.
It's not a,
it's not a thing you can say mean
things.
I would prefer you don't.
We wish we could all be nice to each
other and say lovely things.
They use pronouns.
At the way people want it and all of
those things,
but you can't have the government doing
it.
Is there anything else that I should
have added that,
that perhaps could have gotten those
young people to,
uh,
listen,
that they were disposed not to listen,
but for,
there were obviously some openminded
people in the audience.
And those are the ones that you're,
I mean,
the hecklers,
I think we're,
we're not,
they didn't seem genuinely interested
in,
in hearing you out,
but many other people there did.
And the other point that,
that I would make strategically,
Dave and I already did it,
and pointing out the Martin Luther King
counterpart to the Nazis is I always try
to give an example.
We're an idea that you happen to support
the person I'm talking to.
It really supports would be threatened
if we gave that power to the government.
So,
uh,
for that,
that audience where you had people
chanting black lives matter,
I would have pointed out how many
government officials now are saying
black lives matter advocacy should be
treated as hate speech.
That even saying that black lives matter
should be treated as a hate group,
uh,
the southern poverty law center which
monitors hate groups has been lobbied to
treat black lives matter as such.
And so then you had to say to people,
you have to understand that it's not
your values that are going to be
implemented by the enforcing officials
across the country.
And if we have this loose,
nebulous concept,
I mean hate is an emotion that's
inherently subjective.
What one person considers hateful,
somebody else cherishes.
So you mentioned the southern poverty
law center.
I don't want to get you in any hot water
a,
but they to me,
strike me as an organization that has
completely,
completely with almost no reservation.
Can I say this,
gone off the rails,
but are they have,
you know,
between now they just,
just in this last week,
they,
they lost this lawsuit.
Marginalized is getting a three point
$3,000,000
settlement.
But they had Ayaan Hirsi Ali and
Bridgette Gabriel.
And several other people who I've had
on the show who I think are,
are wonderful people,
uh,
on their hate lists.
They just put up an article about the
evils of prager university and and
called me out by name.
What am I to make of the shifting of
traditionally organizations that were
doing good work into becoming what I
would say are really far left advocacy
groups instead of maybe the original
mission statement.
Would you.
I think that was a fair assessment.
Just not knowledgeable enough about the
instances that you site.
So I'll go back to something I said at
the beginning,
which is I don't endorse or criticize
any organization across the board.
I look at it issue by issue and I think
the southern poverty law center has done
a lot of good work on issues that,
that I care about,
including a freedom of speech on campus.
And they definitely oppose censorship
are including of hate speech.
I testified with a leader of the SPLC,
uh,
before a congress last year and
completely opposed to censorship
completely supporting counter speech.
And in fact,
the SPLC put out a wonderful guide for
college students at the beginning of the
last academic year,
urging them when a white supremacists
recruiters are coming to campus not to
engage in disruption,
not try to censor them or to shout them
down,
but to ignore them.
And I thought that was right,
not only in principle,
but also as a matter of strategy because
you're just playing into their tactics.
Now,
does that mean that every single thing
they've done is,
is,
is praiseworthy?
I doubted I,
I think even the Hclu is not a above.
Yeah,
criticism.
So I know when,
when they sent over some notes about
what we,
what we potentially could talk about
your book and everything else.
Um,
so because you did watch that University
of New Hampshire thing,
there's a moment where a girl that was
challenged me kept implying that it was
free speech,
sort of that led to the Holocaust,
that it was this,
that we,
they allowed incitement.
And that that's what led to it.
Now,
my basic argument was the more speech
there is,
the more we can allow sunlight to
disinfect bad ideas.
But I think perhaps I could have been a
little more forceful there.
If you were standing next to me when we
were doing this,
what would you have been saying in my
ear to that argument that if we just
keep letting people say all these awful
things that it can lead to awful things
and awful things obviously have happened
throughout the course of your years.
I have a lot of answers,
but let me start with the one that is
most specific to the Holocaust.
And again,
I have a personal stake and I know you
also lost relatives in the Holocaust
offer.
Me.
My father fortunately survived,
but he was in a concentration camp and
suffered grievously doing forced labor
and in fact was scheduled to be
sterilized and then was liberated by the
US one day before.
So,
you know,
I almost had my life exterminated before
it began.
I have no love lost for the Nazis are.
In fact,
there was a,
there were hate speech laws in the
Weimar Republic during,
in,
which is in Germany,
where Hitler rose to power and the hate
speech laws were very similar to the
ones that exist in Germany and other
countries today.
They were very strictly enforced.
Nazis were prosecuted and convicted
repeatedly.
And guess what?
They laughed at.
It was a huge propaganda opportunity for
them.
They gained attention and support that
they otherwise never would have had,
just like the Neo Nazis in skokie.
All those years later,
nobody would have heard of them if we
adjust,
allowed them to have their miserable
little march for the 20 minutes to 30
minutes they were seeking to March.
Instead,
it becomes two years worth of worldwide
attention.
Now,
the problem in Nazi in Pre Nazi Germany
was that there was no protection against
violence,
that the Nazis were engaging in a.
so,
uh,
their political opponents as well as
Jews and others were subject literally
to physical assaults and even murder
without any sufficient protection or
punishment.
So the other point I would make is that,
um,
those of us who are minorities and Jews
are a tiny minority in this country and
around the world,
especially depend on freedom of speech
because by definition we're never going
to have majority power.
So all we have to depend on a to limit
the majority from trampling on our
rights is freedom of speech to protest
the First Amendment Right of
association,
uh,
to the right to petition the government
for redress of grievances.
Are Jonathan routes should great gay
rights advocate who my quota,
my work makes the same point about Noah
as a member of sexual orientation.
Minority.
All minorities especially depend on free
speech.
Uh,
I quote all a lot of civil rights
leaders in my book,
Martin Luther King,
the Naacp,
uh,
throughout the civil rights movement
were completely opposed to censorship
including hate speech laws in part
because their speech was viewed as hated
and even hateful and certainly
dangerous.
How concerned are you about
self censorship?
Not not the government doing it,
but what I see more as the sort of the
low level war right now,
which is just the emails that I get
every day about people afraid to speak
up at work.
People are afraid to speak up at
college.
People literally afraid to speak up in
their own homes because they've been so
crushed by political correctness.
They don't want to start fights with
loved ones.
It's.
It's a serious problem and I have to say
it's a difficult problem because to some
extent the point of counter speech,
which I advocated by the way,
that's a legalistic way of saying
anything you disagree with,
you just rate rather than trying to
squelch it,
stopping that expression from coming
out.
You respond to it,
you debate it,
you try to persuade you could Joel,
so that's countering an idea you
disliked with your own speech.
To some extent,
the goal of counter speech is to chill
certain speech and certain ideas,
right?
You want to dissuade somebody from
adhering to white supremacist views.
You don't see it as bad if they self
sensor,
right,
but when does that persuasion cross the
line into bullying or Harrison?
I think that's a very important and
difficult issue,
which was discussed very extensively in
the famous John Stuart Mill Essay on
liberty,
uh,
many people who haven't recently read it
wouldn't be surprised as I was because I
hadn't read it for a few years and keep
a copy of it with me on my travels.
And somebody reminded me that his main
focus there was not on direct government
coercion,
but rather on the social pressure that
is exerted by colleagues,
peers,
civil society,
and in this country.
On the one hand,
I'm very glad that there is such a
robust civil society,
condemnation of racist tweets by
Roseanne Barr to cite a fairly recent
example.
On the other hand,
I'm afraid of the mob ruthlessly
punishing somebody who may have just
said something that's insensitive.
Uh,
and,
and I'm concerned about that,
David.
Not only because I don't want to,
um,
you know,
the mob is no more appealing as a force
that drives certain ideas out of
existence than the government is,
but I'm also concerned from the point of
view of educating and persuading and you
know,
I've met people that have been not only
members,
but leaders of hate groups who have come
to see that they were wrong,
who have come to realize that all of us
are equal and entitled to equal dignity
and equal rights and they've repudiated
their formerly discriminatory ideas and
they didn't come to that change by being
denounced as racists,
much less as what happened in Europe by
being imprisoned as,
as racist.
So if our goal truly is to gain more
support on the part of more people for
the ideals of liberty and justice and
human rights and equality and dignity
for all,
I think we don't do it by,
by shouting them down.
So it's a strategic question as well as
a PR.
A principled question.
Yeah.
Is that just one of those things where
it's like in the moment that we live in,
we often don't live up to our ideals and
the best way possible because you
referenced being constitutional law
professor and I've got the declaration
of independence and the constitution
framed right in that room right over
there and it's like these guys that were
writing these incredible documents that
have given more freedom to more people
than in the history of the world.
Well,
some of them were slave owners and and
plenty of other things and probably
womanizers and whatever and it's like,
but yet they were writing the things
that freed us,
which is an incredible and that's just a
little something about being human.
Nice book and I think it ties back to
some of our earlier conversation that
I'm so much of what passes as debate,
such as your hecklers at the University
of New Hampshire is not genuinely
engaged in really trying to relate to
you as a full fledged human being with
whom they might.
I have absolutely no doubt based on my
experience that there are no two people
in the world who won't have at least
some strong common concern,
some idea that they passion,
that they both deeply care about and are
committed to and and some that they
deeply disagree about and I think it's
really important not to paper over the
disagreements.
I think we should discuss them and hash
them out,
but I think we can do that more
constructively and effectively if we
also find what we have in common and
relate to each other in,
in a holistic way.
Alright.
So there does seem to me to be a rebirth
of a defense of free speech starting
again on the left possibly.
I see a little southern happening.
I did.
Jonathan hated heterodox and some of the
other organizations you're involved in
in fire.
There is this group of people kind of
making a comeback on the left.
I'm not so sure it can hold,
I hope it can hold,
but what do you make of how this sort of
bounces back where sometimes free speech
is something that the left holds more
deer.
Sometimes it's finding the right holds
more deer and it kind of switches as the
decades go ahead
from my perspective,
and I'm not far be it for me to pull out
the age card,
but I think a few more decades than you
have and and it's been a constant that
was very well summed up by nat handoff
home.
You would have loved,
I don't know if you ever crossed paths
with him,
but he was a great free speech stalwart
and he wrote a book whose title really
says it all,
freedom of speech for me,
but not for me,
how the left and right relentlessly
sensor each other and he wrote that
decades ago,
but it's always been true that most
people being ill man,
believe in free speech in general,
thought those ideas that they hate or
despise or think are dangerous should be
the exception.
Let's go back to skokie where a clu
members,
even 15 percent of these die hard
stalwart clu members.
I'm not surprised that the one exception
they want to make is for speech.
That's Dan grading,
civil liberties and human rights,
but I had a friend who was the executive
director of the National Coalition
Against Censorship and she put it so
well.
She said Nadine,
everyone has his or her skokie.
So at particular times I can tell you
for every year I can tell you this was
the one exception or maybe more than one
exception that liberals want to make and
this is the one that conservatives
wanted to make.
And I would say in general,
you know,
like,
um,
uh,
let's amend the constitution so that it
is a crime to burn the American flag
that has been supported by many,
if not most conservatives and by a lot
of liberals as well.
That.
And there's not been,
I think that is the single most hated
expression in my lifetime because no
other expression has led to a
constitutional amendment coming within a
hair's breadth of being ratified more
than two thirds of the Senate.
I'm sorry if the House approved,
it came within one vote short of two
thirds of the Senate and more than three
fourths of the states.
So all of it.
That's when was that?
Maybe that was mid nineties.
Maybe something around there.
Wow.
That's incredible actually,
if you think about it.
Yeah.
Where,
where do you think trump kind of fits
into the general discussion?
Because he loved.
It seems to me that there is obviously
some sort of authoritarian bent to him.
That being said,
we're not being.
People are,
as far as I know people are being jailed
because of free speech at the moment.
Do you think our institutions,
let's say that his worst critics,
we're write about whatever they think
about him.
Do you think our institutions at this
point are strong enough to ward off that
kind of threat and we don't even have to
make it about trump specifically,
but if there was truly like a real
authoritarian in office,
do you think that the way our balance of
powers and our separation of powers
works,
and again,
I would have to say,
you know,
trump has certainly done a lot of saber
rattling on free speech issues and you
know,
said that flag burners should be
deported.
But let us not forget that Barack Obama
was responsible for,
uh,
the most stringent enforcement of the
espionage act and you know,
pressing criminal charges against more
whistleblowers than all or prior
administrations added together.
So again,
a pox on both your houses.
So far,
the courts have been a wonderful
bulwark.
The flag burning example is a really
good one.
It was a two supreme court decisions
joined by both conservatives and
liberals on the court that struck down
under the First Amendment,
laws that criminalized desecrating the
American flag.
Well,
the Supreme Court doesn't have quite the
last word,
a constitutional amendment could
overturn it,
but I have great confidence that this
court would continue to uphold what has
been called the bedrock principle of
freedom of speech and that his viewpoint
neutrality.
I summarized it earlier,
that the mere fact that the viewpoint is
hated,
whether it be flag burning or whether it
be racist speech that has never adjusted
vacation for censorship again,
they unanimously endorsed that last
summer in a hate speech case.
Yeah.
Well,
it's slightly shift for a second.
So when you were the head of the Acu,
what are the political pressures that
you're under that maybe the average
person wouldn't know from the,
from the headlines,
like involvement with politicians,
with lobbyists,
etc.
Etc.
So at thE acl you was at his and I was
personally involved in lobbying and
testifying.
I still do to testify before congress
occasionally.
Uh,
and I would say to me it was a very
privileged position because we did not
have to be directly concerned about
partisan political pressures.
We could Simply make alliances and work
with anybody that we thought could
support an issue that advanced our cars
even if we disagreed with them on other
issues.
And I remember,
uh,
to me it was a great source of pleasure.
I remember on one piece of legislation
testifying before the senate judiciary
committee and the chair was orrin hatch
and the ranking a minority minority
member was ted kennedy.
and they were both supportIng the same
pro civil liberties positions.
And I was testifying together with the
head of the national association of
evangelicalism and the head of the
mormon church.
And despite all of the differences on so
many other issues,
the fact that we could make common
concern that was on principles of
religious liberty and freedom of thought
and freedom of belief,
that's what I feel is deteriorating a
little bit.
Uh,
so last year I testified a couple of
times on campus free speech issues and
the bipartisanship had really worn down
even though the theme was freedom of
speech on.
And even though the chair of the
committee who was lamar alexander
republican and patty murray,
the ranking member democrat,
they were both really solid and great on
the issue,
but the other members of the committee
just used it as opportunities to try it
out.
Their own ideas of which free speech was
bad and should be suppressed.
So some of the republicans were saying
taking a knee by athletes should be
punished.
And some of the democrats were really
saying trump is violating free speech.
And there was too much political
grandstanding.
And that's why for as critical as I am
for the left,
I don't want free speech to become.
I don't want it to be a political issue
in the first place.
I don't want it to be that the right,
which at the moment I see more tolerance
related to diversity of ideas.
I don't want that to be the home.
I want there to be a balance.
Otherwise we're just going to end up in
that.
Maybe a little bit skeptical,
but I think that people tend to be
result oriented and that,
uh,
on the right,
there may be much more support for
freedom of speech on campus because they
see that it's views on the right that
are being squelched now.
In fairness,
I'll give you a counterexample,
uh,
many years ago during this first surge
of political correctness on campus,
mitch mcconnell,
um,
uh,
let me,
let me put it backwards.
It was Henry Hyde,
I'm sorry,
a conservative catholic from Illinois
who was completely on the opposite side
of the acl,
you on abortion and gay rights.
And he really was so strong on campus
free speech that he sponsored a bill
that would have required all private
universities to respeCt the same free
speech rights that public universities
are required to observe under the
constitution.
Many people don't know this,
but the constitution only applies to
government including state universities,
but not private university.
How did you guys feel about.
Well,
we totally supportive the legis.
Again,
that would be a difference between
libertarians and civil libertarians.
My libertarian friends would say,
keep the government out of it,
let the private institutions decide.
And there were exemptions for religious
institutions.
But basically I think that's where I
would fall on this.
So sell me,
sell me yoU your way then.
It's a very interesting debate and I can
understand,
um,
but the person,
and you know,
I've had this discussion with my dear
friends of the cato institute for many,
many years now.
What's the difference between a
classical liberal or libertarian is
civil libertarian?
Uh,
I think that we are less opposed to
government regulation when it is in the
service of regulating very powerful
private sector actors that for all
practical purposes,
the way we were talking about civil
society earlier can exercise coercive
power that stifles people's liberty.
So,
so what if you,
uh,
if you,
if,
if we did not have the 19,
64 civil rights act than even the most
powerful large landlord,
employer,
corporation,
private university or etc,
would be able to discriminate on the
basis of race or gender under federal
law.
They still can on the basis of sexual
orientation,
I would view that as something that
could and should be remedied through
passing a statute.
Making that illegal.
So usually report into,
well I think.
Well first off,
I agree with you your basic premise
here,
just at the idea level,
it's a great place for a rich
conversation.
Yeah.
The idea that the government would be
coming in and telling private schools,
even though I understand what you're
saying,
that they would have to adhere to these
codes.
Even if I being the first amendment,
I don't necessarily think of private
school should have to do that.
I just think that ultimately the market
would.
You'd either decide you want to go there
or don't want to go there.
This one,
this one is definitely a tough one for
me.
It's an interesting one and I definitely
can see the other side and I certainly
would insist on some exemptions.
Certainly for religious schools.
I think military schools were also
exempt it.
But then I want to give you another
example of a republican that I worked
with,
mitch mcconnell,
uh,
worked very closely with the acl in
opposing.
Many people are going to be surprised to
hear this.
The mccain feingold law a campaign,
so-called campaign finance like a
lifetime ago.
We don't talk about that.
A clu very,
you know,
we're the ones who argued buckley versus
valeo and arguing that the ability to
spend money in order to promote a
message is protected free speech and it
should be protected even when the speech
is engaged in by people who are
organized into a group and including if
they're organized in the form of a
corporation or a union or not for profit
corporation.
so some liberals are really distressed
by that position and I think it's
absolutely the correct line anyway.
What do you say to those?
Those liberals are the lefties who do
get more upset about that in general,
that you're just going to allow
corporations to endlessly pour money in
the system and manipulate the system.
And that's it.
Well,
again,
what is the lesser of two evils?
Would I rather have the government
telling corporations such as the acl,
you and planned parenthood and the
sierra club,
you name your favorite left wing,
so called cause and it is organized
incorporate form and the acu under that
law was,
it would have been a crime to go on the
airwaves and by name call on people who
are running for federal office and say,
you know,
repeal the patriot act,
uh,
because arguing for issues over the
broadcast airwaves was a crime under
that law and spending your own money to
advance your own issue oriented message.
So I think people are shocked When they
hear what the law actually did and are
persuaded that in at least some
applications that went too far.
Well,
mcconnell became such a supporter of
free speech as a result of working on
this issue that he actually changed his
position on the flag burning amendment.
He had been a big proponent of it and
having seen how important freedom of
speech was including for what to
liberals,
is a very controversial form of speech,
namely spending money in the political
process.
He said,
well,
you know,
I've got to stick to principles here and
we should not amend the constitution to
outlaw another controversial expression.
So I thought that was a really wonderful
idea of not just being result oriented
toward your own ideological concerns,
but seeing the overarching principle and
following it.
It's almost like if you actually have
the debate,
you might change people's mind and be
surprised who your allies are.
Is there any country that is protecting
these rights better than we are for as
screwy as our system may be?
No.
Uh,
well let me make a,
a on sexual expression.
The United States is a much more
repressive than a european.
Some many european countries.
But like in what regard?
You mean with what can be seen in
magazines or.
yeah,
so we still have a,
I mean not only sexual expression but
four letter words.
I mean,
thank goodness we're not broadcasting
because I still get bleeped even when I
try to do whatever you want,
all seven of them.
Well,
and,
and one of them appears,
and I'm not even sure if this was one of
these seven,
but fuck,
the draft was upheld as of in a very
important free speech case.
It that by the United States supreme
court and it's a case that has
ramifications for hate speech as well,
but I cannot describe the facts of that
case on radio or tv and you know,
that's,
that's laughable.
And other countries and we still have
anti obscenity.
Well,
I mean,
let's not forget that the brouhaha about
the,
the wardrobe malfunction at super bowl,
I mean it's,
so we're much more puritanical,
but when it comes to political
expression,
there is no country that gives as much
protection as we do,
including for hateful,
racist speech and misogynistic speech,
including for defamation,
you know,
a defamatory falsehoods about public
officials and public figures.
And that's why,
uh,
there are so many libel lawsuits that
are brought in the uk against what would
be clearly protected speech in this
country.
Yeah.
But you do believe in our libel laws
here.
Uh,
yes,
I,
you know,
I'm sure I would want to trim them back
a little bit,
but on the whole were quite protective.
So if it's a matter of public concern or
public official or public figure,
you get quite a bit of leeway.
You can't be held culpable unless you
have acted intentionally or recklessly.
and I think that's correct.
And one of the things they're pretty
specific.
Yeah.
One of the things that trump wanted to
do as he said was to reform the libel
laws to make it easier for a public
official to,
to collect damages.
And you know,
a lot of people say,
oh,
come on to dean britain and Germany and
France and Canada and Australia,
you know,
it's not as if they are to tell a in
authoritarian countries,
but if you read the examples in my book
of the kinds of speech that are being
punished even with imprisonment,
even with a criminal fines.
And that's the tip of the iceberg
because for every punishment there is,
there are countless numbers of,
of self censorship incidence.
It would really make your skin crawl.
But give examples,
no matter what your ideology is,
you should find something in there that
you would say,
oh my goodness,
I can't believe it.
So,
you know,
uh,
France,
a couple of years ago,
criminally convicted,
they had a gay rights organization for
calling the head of an anti gay rights
organization off homophobe that was
considered to be hate speech.
Now,
fortunately she wasn't sentenced to
prison,
but she was subject to a very stiff,
fine,
$3,500.
Uh,
and,
and then you think,
what are the ripple effects of that?
Yeah.
Have you guys track this case with,
uh,
the comedian in the uk who had the dog?
Oh,
yes,
absolutely.
Yes.
I mean,
again,
like,
it's like,
all right,
first off he was making a joke.
there's no,
there's no exception for humor or satire
when the new online hate speech laws
went into effect in Germany on January
1st,
the first person convicted or charged
under it was one of the leaders of a
right wing party.
Not surprisingly,
but the very in the.
MAybe the first two that were charged
were from that party,
but the very next one was a satirical
magazine that was making fun of their
statements,
mocking them,
ridIculing and,
and,
and these laws by being so subjective
can't make the fine distinctions between
humor,
satire and straightforward advocacy.
Yeah.
So my audience knows I'm not big on the
globalist ideas here or even the un I
think is mostly a forest at this point,
but do we need some sort of internet
bill of rights?
I mean this is a new phrase that we're,
that seems to be popping up over the
last year or so that will uniformly
protect people in other country from,
be for their ability to say things that
are uncomfortable online and be able to
tweet things,
uh,
that,
you know,
you can't say in Germany,
but you can say in the United States,
I,
I think we have to do that on a country
by country basis.
And I am pleased that there are
advocates in other countries that really
strongly support freedom of speech,
including for hate speech.
I keep putting that in air quotes
because it is,
as I say to that person and you're at
the university of New Hampshire now,
there really is no such thing.
And by the way,
there are a lot of what they saId to
you.
Some people would consider to be hate
speech too.
So that's another argument that you
could have made.
Do you realize that's my one regret is
at one point when she said to me,
I said something about losing holocaust,
a family members from august on both
sides and then later she said they're
rolling in their graves over what I'm
saying.
I mean,
trying to think like if this,
if we're really,
if we're really gauging the offense
meter,
I assure you there was nothing that I
said in those two hours that was more
wildly offensive than that.
But do I want her jailed because of
that?
I mean,
of course not.
Yeah.
So I,
I really was heartened at how much
support there is for the american
approach.
We,
we're often,
uh,
attacked as being american
exceptionalists and it wouldn't bother
me if we were the only ones in the,
in the world that we're defending our
free speech principles as long as that
is the right thing to do,
but it's interesting that other people
having seen despite the good intentions
of sensorial laws elsewhere,
how they are leading to results that no
thinking person should accept and
handing over to these online.
So here we get to this question again,
and I'll put it this way,
dave,
what's the lesser of two evils to allow
these private,
uh,
agglomerations of power,
internet and companies decide,
pick and choose whose speech is allowed
and who's not,
and enforcing their own concepts of hate
speech or pornography or permissible or
impermissible nudity to pick just a few
examples that they enforce.
Would I rather have them have that
enormouS power or would I rather have
the government say,
no,
we're gonna check your power to restrict
other people's free speech rights and
it,
to me that's a very difficult.
Yeah.
So that's it.
Okay.
So that's exactly where we were before
with the universities.
That's where I would say ultimately
right now are for,
I don't know how many internet companies
we have,
let's say comcast spectrum.
They're all one at some level.
Yeah.
You're of the net neutrality issue and
I'm thinking of the social media that
you know,
the facebooks and the twitters having
these armies of enforcer saying that's
hate speech.
We're going to take it down.
Right.
So I guess what I would say is that if
there were certain internet companies
that were saying,
all right,
well we're not going to allow
pornography on our pipes or we're not
going to allow this type of speech or
that type of speech.
I would still prefer that you as the
consumer would have more choice than
than the government saying we have to
enforce all these things.
But because of the,
because of the internet,
now I know this is a unique situation
related to free speech.
That's a little.
I mean,
in my ideal world,
I'm completely with you.
The question is,
and I'm not an economist,
my husband is,
and he tells me that it's very
complicated.
Have some of them amassed so much power
that we should use the antitrust type
tools to prevent them for that,
that they are denying us choice through
their market power.
Right?
So this is,
there's a great conversation to be had
there.
This is where my friends had prager
university who I agree with on all sorts
of stuff.
They were suing google,
youtube over restrictions to their
videos,
which I was in for because I don't want
the antitrust stuff to be in because to
me that,
that then means you Just create a
zillion other problems down the road.
But that's a great place for a free
speech person and an economist and
probably a technology guy to all sit
down and work this stuff out without
choking each other.
There was a real,
to me really frightening story in the
New York times a few weeks ago featuring
a faCebook's deletion center.
That's what it was actually called,
this huge building in berlin where they
had literally hundreds of people that
are looking at individual posts and
deciding should this be deleted and
should have not been deleted.
And it was,
um,
you know,
and the examples,
you,
you realize how inevitably subjective it
is.
Ultimately they took down when they took
down this,
this comment that was posted by the
politician,
she was calling certain muslim men
rapists.
And the question was,
was she referring to the particular
muslim immigrants who were in fact a
convicted rapist?
There was a hOrrible incident on new
year's eve a couple of years ago,
in wHich case one would hope that would
be protected speech because she's
describing something factual or was she
perhaps insinuating that all muslim men
are rapists?
Which would not be a generalization that
I would find objectionable,
but,
and,
but it would be illegal under german
law.
And the official,
you know,
these people,
it's their whole job to make these
decisions.
They couldn't agree between themselves.
and so of course,
if you're not sure which way it goes and
you're facing a 50 million euro,
fine.
If the german government says it is hate
speech,
while guess what,
what,
what do you think right now is our
biggest censorship threat?
Where do you think is coming on the
horizon?
I'm going to be very general because
it's been the same answer had throughout
my decades of activism,
which is lack of public understanding
and awareness of whaT the first
amendment is,
what it does protect,
what it does not protect what the
rationales are.
I truly believe that the more people
understand both what the principles are
and how we have evolved at toward those
principles,
through historic experience that people
will be supportive.
So I'm curious during the whole nfl
Kneeling thing,
I've made a couple of videos about it
and obviously we talked about it on the
show,
but I basically was saying,
look,
this is free speech working.
The president sAid what he said now I
would certainly prefer that the
president not call people sons of
bitches.
Right?
But he's entitled to free speech.
He didn't try to enact a law to stop
him,
so he spoke.
The players could then deal or not neil,
so they were able to do what they
wanted.
The owners could then,
you know,
find the players or not.
So they got to do what they wanted.
The fans could say,
I'm going to buy jerseys and a 10 games
or I'm not good new,
so everyone speech,
actually everyone's speech and action
was protected.
You might have some consequences for it,
but to me it was a great example of the
whole thing working messy but working.
Do you think?
Fair summation,
totally agree with that and I had a
quite similar analysis myself to the
disappointment of people who did not
realize that the nfl as a private entity
has its own rights,
including its own free speech rights and
I thought it was interesting that some
of the owners said they would allow
their players to express their protest.
Is in that case though,
is trump getting it as close to where it
could be an issue for the acl,
you or other similar organizations as he
can without directly calling for a law
because there is some other.
I don't even know what that phrase is,
but there's something else happening
there when he's calling you or
threatening if he were threatening to
pass a law and he did that in one other
context.
I think he threatened that there should
be some f an fcc license should be taken
away from some broadcasts or that comes
much closer to the line and the
principal.
Dave,
you're exactly right.
He does not give up his free speech
rights by virtue of being a government
official,
but if he is speaking in official
capacity,
um,
and threatening some adverse
consequences that could be seen as an
abridgment of free speech under which
would violate the frasers amendment.
ExActly.
Uh,
so in the past,
I think the closest supreme court case
we have is we're a government commission
wrote a letter that threatened that It
would take some action and even though
it wasn't starting a prosecution or it
wasn't an order to cease the expression,
the court said,
you know,
it was a very functional,
practical concept.
It would a reasonable person feel
deterred in pursuing their free speech
after they hear this communication.
And again,
reasonable people can disagree about
what the answer to that is,
but that's the question we should put in
evaluating whether trump has crossed the
line or not.
So one of the things that I saw when the
nfl released its new standard now for
next season where the players are
allowed to stay in the locker room or
not.
and again,
everyone's choice will,
will or will not have consequence.
I saw a lot of people that were sayiNg,
well clearly the government involved,
you know,
interfered behind the scenes.
Now I know there's no,
I know you don't.
I suspect you don't have some sort of
insider knowledge on something like
thAt.
That's where there would be a problem
though if they were really,
you know,
behind the scenes meetings where they
were saying you're going to institute
this new policy.
But beyond that,
but short of having that information,
everything kind of work.
Yeah,
I'm there.
There's another analogy I can think of,
which is where the government has
threatened certain businesses that if
you don't adopt a voluntary,
a restriction on speech,
then we're going to pass legislation.
So for example,
the movie rating system or a sound
recording rating systems that we think
these labels are stigmatizing and
therefore suppressing certain
expression,
uh,
I think there's a very strong argument
that the only reason this so called
voluntary system,
uh,
was put in place in both businesses is
because they knew that if they didn't do
it,
the government was going to legislate
it.
Uh,
but even that,
the supreme court never held that that
was illegal censorship.
Yeah.
All right.
Well we can't talk free speech for an
hour and not mention the cake.
We got to talk about the gay k.
Jake,
tell Me your thoughts on the gay cake.
Okay.
It's a I.
First of all,
I think it involves not only expression,
which I would define quite broadly.
And again,
let me talk about the,
the standard here.
Reasonable people can disagree how the
standard applies to the facts of the
case.
So the court has said,
and I think this is correct,
that something comes,
some expression comes or arguable
expression comes within the ambit of the
first amendment.
If it is intended to And can reasonably
perceived as conveying a message,
at least a general message.
So that's the question you would ask
about the cake.
I think there's at least a plausible
argument that the cake satisfied that
standard,
uh,
in addition to expression,
there's the question of religious
liberty,
right?
Which I defend very strongly,
even more strongly than the supreme
court,
which has a quite narrow definition now,
uh,
but I think people should not be coerced
generally to do something that violates
their deeply held religious or
conscientious beliefs.
That's only one of the equation though,
because neither freedom of speech nor
religious freedom is absolute.
And in general,
the court has said,
and I think this is right,
that government can restrict those
freedoms if it can show that there is a
countervailing interests,
have such compelling importance that can
only be advanced by restricting the
expression or the belief.
Uh,
and the countervailing interest is of
course the dignity and equality of a,
in this case gay people.
But in past cases,
it's been african americans or women
because people have cited who are in
business,
have asserted religious justifications
for not serving members of racial
minorities or not treating women
equally.
And,
but to be clear,
that's not what was happening here
because they could have walked in and
bought any cake off the shelf.
A black person,
an interracial couple could have a
walked in and bought any cake off the
shelf.
This was about this specific act that
was going to be paint,
you know,
painted or whatever they do on the case.
Right.
You know,
it's interesting.
I,
uh,
and there's another,
um,
another free speech principle that's
involved here,
which is that government may not compel
somebody to proclaim a certain message
that they don't believe in anymore than
it may stop somebody from conveying a
message that they,
that they do believe in a.
So I would say I,
I'm,
I'm very,
I think they're very strong concerns on
both sides.
So I'm very sympathetic because.
Let me finish out the other argument.
Of course,
if you're an independent artist that is,
you know,
only taking assignments on commission,
whether it be to paint a portrait or a
landscape or to decorate a cake and a
very elaborate way.
That's one thing.
But if you are doing business with the
general public and basically holding
yourself out as what the law would call
a public accommodation,
we're open to all commerce,
then you may not discriminate on certain
bases such as race,
religion and I think even though you
still can as a matter of federal law
under state law in that state and and,
and others,
you cannot do that on the basis of
sexual orientation.
And so I think that very strong
countervailing equality principle I
think should,
should dominate in,
in this analysis.
So you actually weren't thrilled with
this decision that.
Well I was.
I was in the sense that there were so
many ways that the court could have gone
wrong,
have so many issues.
They said that it was not the best thing
they could do was to be very narrow.
And I actually,
if I were writing of the brief in the
case,
that's what I would do too,
because all of these principles are so
important.
I deeply care about freedom of
expression,
including the freedom not to be
compelled to affirm a message that,
that violates your beliefs,
whether they're religious or
conscientious,
doesn't matter.
Um,
but I also deeply believe in equality in
the public sphere and the facts were
murky.
So I think,
you know,
as I think what happened in past
situations with race and gender,
I think,
you know,
once things,
once the immediate resistance died down
to the 1964 civil rights act,
that it sort of worked its way out in a
way that is maximally respective
respectful of all the competing.
Right.
So I think it's very good to avoid
really broad brush holdings that might
have unanticipated adverse consequences
for other factual situations.
But that's an interesting take because I
saw some people saying,
well they're just sort of kicking this
down the road now.
But basically you're saying in a weird
way that's the way a functional society
works at times.
I think,
you know,
the court sets them general goal posts
and then as time goes by,
the controversy may die down.
People may figure out how they can live
their own lives in ways that they're not
going to be bothered by,
by the government not being treated
disrespectfully.
One of the things that I really liked
about the opinion in that case,
and,
uh,
it's so contrasting to what's happening
in the european countries that I discuss
in my book is that the court talked very
strongly about equality and neutrality
in many different,
sorry,
in many different contexts.
So not only that you should be treated
with equal dignity regardless of who you
are,
but also regardless of what you believe.
So the fact that the court was
respectful,
both of the equal dignity of the gay
couple and have the equal dignity of
their religious beliefs and the free
speech rights of the baker.
I really liked that.
Um,
one of the things that bothers me very
much about what a,
is often paraded as diversity on campus
is that it only looks at one dimension.
It looks at demographic diversity in
terms of who you are,
but not in terms of,
of what you believe.
And in these european countries that are
enforcing hate speech laws,
you see them going both ways depending
on who's in power.
So certain religious beliefs are being
punished and criminalized as hate speech
If they run against what is a dominant
secular orthodoxy in those societies.
Uh,
whereas in other communities,
a certain criticism of religion is
treated as hate speech and criminalized
when it's the religious belief that is
held by those in dominant power.
I think the main takeaway here is that
freedom is messy,
but we're doing a pretty decent job of
it here.
Well,
thanks to those who keep agitating,
right?
Eternal vigilance go well.
It's been a pleasure chatting with you
and for more on a dean,
check out her new book hate why we
should resist it with free speech,
not censorship,
and we're going to link to it right down
below.